um a lying Republican now says that when
you call out her lies you're being
anti-hispanic this is exactly the
nonsense that the right accuses the left
of doing I will remind you that there is
this new Republican congresswoman Anna
Paulina Luna she lied about being Jewish
we talked about it yesterday she's not
actually Jewish she has since been
called out for her lies she says to
Charlie Kirk during an appearance
yesterday that when her lies are called
out it is anti-hispanic that's an
interesting perspective let's listen and
to say that I would make something like
that up why would they say that it's
because they don't want young Hispanics
to be reputable and if you look at the
slant of the entire article they say
that I'm not Hispanic enough even though
they cite where my grandparents
immigrated from but you know a lot of
what they do it's character
assassination and if you don't have a
spine for it you can fold but I think
that we launched a full frontal assault
and we'll look forward to more
attraction soon yeah
despite the claims of Republicans it is
actually Republicans who regularly play
the victim card this is another example
of accusations or confessions this is
another example of projection this is
another example of the right developing
a narrative about the left that applies
more to them than it does to the left
Republicans often claim
that the left always are victims we're
victims of racism say the leftists were
victims of xenophobia were victims of
sexism the leftists they want to be
victims but when you actually look
you see that Republicans have been
playing the victims for a long time now
the war on Christmas the Christians were
being victimized the war on religion the
claims aren't backed by evidence they
use them to Rally their base they use
them to raise money they use them to
purport to be the victims of some
liberal agenda oh the if you're straight
you're now being attacked just for being
straight another example they say we're
victims of election fraud there's no
evidence to support that and in fact
when individual perpetrators of
so-called election fraud are found they
are almost always Republicans either
trying to test the system or simply
trying to vote multiple times they say
the left does it
they're they're the ones getting caught
doing it okay they said an entire
election was stolen from them Trump's
new thing uh no nobody's been treated
more unfairly than my family all my
friends do you have friends sir all my
friends tell me nobody's been treated as
unfairly as you have but the left
they're the ones who play the victim and
then of course they often claim to be
the victims of discrimination or
sometimes they'd like to use the term
reverse discrimination or Reverse Racism
or whatever the case may be and yet when
you actually look at studies you find
that it is people of color communities
of color marginalized groups who are
more likely to actually be discriminated
against and so by claiming to be the
victims of discrimination they they deny
the experiences of people who are
actually the victims of discrimination
they distract from real issues and of
course they become that which they
criticize the left for being and this is
yet another example they're going after
me for being Hispanic no they're going
after you for being a liar
that's what this is at the end of the
day and so I don't really know the best
strategy for the left on this because if
you're on the left and you identify an
injustice you've gone woke you're
playing the victim card whatever
but then when they do it themselves and
we call it out because the right doesn't
care about hypocrisy anymore if they
ever did and because the right has
abandoned policy their voters don't
actually care they fall for Gaff they're
going after Anna Paulina Luna because
she's a proud conservative Hispanic
woman no they're going after her because
she's a liar and she deserves it quite
simply